hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
candy's 3 now we're going to continue
with the fourth night now I'll try to
beat that and then I'm going to try to
be the fifth night and then hopefully
save the 6th night for something else
but I wanted to test an idea that I had
which was I'm running um so maybe the
answer is not to run because when you
run you drippy drop the slips blocks and
that's why there's a timer because that
would make more sense as to you taking
your time not in the darkness
oh I just saw the ride it was just
sitting in the darkness so it really
doesn't like me oh hey do you see that
everybody I do okay alright well that
makes so much more sense I'm a big dumb
idiot then I've been doing the dumb
thing this whole time okay the brand-new
horror films psychopath starring Lizzie
Hydra dungeon has broken box-office
records in its first week everyone
agrees that the starting actor sold the
performance of the psychopath like no
one else could have maybe because she
was one of those Psychopaths so that
must be why he shouldn't walked in front
of its face that was my first mistake
I'm the big dummy so that's why he was
so aggressive because in the darkness
right there he's actually just sitting
there but he is honestly actually just
kind of sitting there whoo
hey buddy you're nearby is this the same
article I don't remember there being
someone yeah is the same one well
remember there being someone up there
okay alright then if I just meander
around and then start wandering into the
darkness I keep my eyes peeled friend
you know face is the problem I'm lost
I'm scared and alone and lost
and I'm an idiot who is running
everywhere God so and please end my
suffering and give me something to hope
hi
okay so I gotta go somewhere logical
I'll be right back ah hello gents
that's is what I am haha right okay
boy then so I'm sorry that I was such a
goddamn fool and not not doing this
right because that was foolish of me and
that explains why there's a timer now
and that explains why it was just an
Lee's death oh hello where are you
the dream trees will show you the path
will be now there's nothing on the back
alrighty then will they show me the path
I hope so okay alright there's a lot of
rats in these dark woods hey do that to
me there's a goddamn rap there's a
goddamn rat here somewhere where are you
facing down that time [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
oh there we got what we got huh huh huh
okay all right everybody calm down that
was not did not warrant panic of that
degree okay I made it where am I now
whoo hello ready then give give give you
I found arcade game number three part
two so was in a different zone I wasn't
gonna be able to get that no matter what
I did here you is this is one more way
for me to go before the cat gets me the
timer runs out and then I Drive so there
was another way to go up this way I just
got to be mindful of goddamn rods Wow
haha can't see it okay you know what I
got what I needed again I got the arcade
game and so you guys have also been
telling me then I need to play the
goddamn arcade games so once I beat the
[ __ ] out of this Knight which I'm gonna
do hook wait y'all I'm gonna play these
some arcade games take the ILO's of
everybody that thinks that they can be
better than way it is Oh game so let's
get into this I'm so ready giving me an
opportunity to shame your stupid ashes
now you guys you dumbass cat
animatronics you want to rip my gosh
ouch
hi okay bye have fun masturbating in the
corner of the back room over there you
could love your company all cat wants to
come out and play he's not gonna give me
today I got my volume cranked way the
hell up it's gonna be bad my kid john
caird i told you though thig you can
shaniek on me in the immortal words of
my own mother don't sneak on me Freddie
don't try to sneak on me
yeah what was that hi oh hey how's it
going there friend ooh
so I was comfortable and I got eyes
peering at me from the darkness you'll
either shut your eyes pull them out or
go [ __ ] yourself one of the three
options that we got here hey buddy you
didn't you guys are little I've eaten
anything I got a little bit of this
treat everybody do a good old time here
well I saw you pop up there don't even
try it okay goodbye
people are being real frisky tonight I'm
sorry I can't entertain you I'm a little
girl and I need to get my beauty sleep
because I am a young child who probably
needs to get a normal amount of rest and
having constant nightmares probably
detrimental to both my education and my
overall health so I don't want to
continue down this road right [ __ ] off
with you you're goddamn creepy son of an
ass stop it don't do that yeah blink
away the pain ah well that's not good
someone's in my room stinky soggy snippy
snobby one I'm missing my targets by big
time this time
Lou Lou ah brick under my bed how can
this be what site is you on that's right
ah okay you first
home and then the kitty cat he was
breathing up a storm of his boy whoa
that is that is astonishingly close to
me
Hey don't stand so close to me she's
gotten my thing rewinding but it was a
little bit preoccupied by there being
rats and cats inside my hats and also my
room I don't know what else they're
doing with everything but I think it
might be in part of everything that's
going wrong here
hello you doodle doo ah who's that got
you and got you get out of here kitty
cat I don't want to know what's new I
want you to go for a girl come on dear
whoa you see you I don't even know how
you get in there what makes sense
I got like a wardrobe to Narnia in the
middle of my goddamn bedroom here I knew
it
ah go away Bing bong Bing all right
Jimmy give you your baby to boot come on
come on here we go good Bob baby boo
anybody want to mess with me oh hey
well you didn't volunteer it kind of ran
away I know I know it's me markiplier
it's okay
treat me like a normal human I'm sorry
if I cry on you I don't like that I
don't like that at all hey hey I said I
didn't like that
oh geez so mobile right now come on stop
being such a douche nozzle what are you
doing that guy here Rick you made me
miss my target
you got damned uber nuber you dick
longer never quiet when you're sneaking
out under the bed
you're never gonna I'm gonna get away
from the parents and you keep sneaks
knocking like that goddammit I didn't
remind my goddamn ship oh I did okay
never mind then I need to stop being so
mean about myself and I need to start
recognizing that I am a proud individual
who can do what he intends to do Mosul's
down and out really always I'm gonna
make it through this night you synthesis
some sons of thunder stitches some since
a spider ah [ __ ] me I stopped it mid
recording and
I can you know just a timeout exactly
when I need to actually redo the thing
which might be important for strategies
down the road oh come on with this
[ __ ] dammit how can you be looking
one direction then you're not looking
hello goodbye okay oh hey you were right
in the middle of there I was about to
backtrack over there but I guess you're
too much of an idiot actually take
advantage of all my weaknesses it's okay
I know it's not good being that
unintelligent but you know it is what it
is what what was that
who's there tonight did I stop somebody
I didn't even try to do that that just
kind of happened on its own so I don't
know what I should do
who's there who's knocking up a Sherman
don't do that
don't let appreciate it oh hey I'm a
stopped test rewound it walk pool snip
sobbing oh you're not gonna fool me this
time I know where you're going from and
I know where you came from so cotton
eyed Joe taking the long way back home
ah [ __ ] Knicks hi
same old song and dance we've been doing
for a long time mr. Atticus I don't know
what to tell you about all this [ __ ]
but you need to settle the [ __ ] down
nope I'm okay alright then hello mister
you I gotta take care of a cat problem
that I got on the other side of bed
alright he's gonna be over here Hey back
down there sonny jim all right we want
oh it's already rewound it was already
kind hello hi okay go away and I'm gonna
be mindful of you ass bags you
douche-nozzles need to tone it down a
little bit I'm at five a.m. and I'm
gonna get out of here I'm gonna go hey
my don't nobody think about here you get
down but you get you get to put down I'm
gonna get out here we'll survive this
night it's the last thing I do I'm gonna
live I guess if it was the last thing I
do I exactly not live but hey don't take
my semantics against me I'm a little
girl I don't know what the hell I'm
talking about half the time so you just
should forget let me live my life good
way who's there
Oh goodbye Wow the hell keeps knocking
on my bed frame hey I made it okay so
now when I give him to this goddamn
arcade I can actually play this goddamn
game supposedly I don't understand know
about that but I'm gonna try my best I
may be playing those games beside the
playing friggin hide-and-seek all the
time it's gonna be a little bit better
for me I'm gonna go over here I'm gonna
ignore what you have to say no I won't
be your friend no I don't think they
want to be your friend either something
anyone wants to be your friend so I hit
a wall there
or Astro pinball jungle pinball wacom
old high n I didn't get to be here the
past two days where the shows good I bet
they were at least I get to be here to
celebrate Vinnie's birthday I'm really
excited
who the heck is Benny and also why can't
I play arcade games I don't know but at
least I can stay out of Benny are you
Benny
I heard that the cat and the rat
actually have real names they're
supposed to be secret
for now I think their cat's name is Carl
Carl it attacked
maybe the rats name is Roger he seems
like a Roger to me or maybe he has a
name that rhymes with the cats me just
like cat and rat rhyme the names could
rhyme to Carl and RORO RORO I have no
idea I don't think that works out kid
you didn't think that too hard
hi sweetie today's Vinnie's birthday
wanna go say hello to him after the show
Oh was Benny the kid that I ignored all
that poor kid well I told him to shut
the [ __ ] up on his own birthday so
that's probably not very good for me
kind of creeped out from this place
I think it's haunted I was listening
through this door in a moment ago I
heard someone crying in there could it
be a ghost bear employees only no it's
just the people who play the cat in
there and their stressful lives they
just have to play hide and seek with
kids that don't like him not a very
rewarding job I'll admit but somebody's
got to do it
why not these [ __ ] are you Benny oh
hi again I didn't get to be here this
early yesterday but I was there when the
show started I don't know if you noticed
me no I didn't happy birthday [ __ ]
alright where's the birthday boy are you
gonna play hide and seek with me also
what's on this show nothing okay hello
there on the card you like to play games
hi what Tsang we've met already
hallo I don't remember that cute little
face anyway anyway you missed us no sirs
you wanna play hide and seek with me
oh this cute little face once planned
seek with you yes you're right you hide
and I'll count yeah hi in here please
Becky hi
five minutes this is gonna be good I
know this game's gonna be just good
every other game can I hide in this
pinball I'm hiding a whack-a-mole
please please I'm begging you dad okay I
need you to protect me under this one
you know I'm gonna hide under the coffee
table because I need some Joe here to
get through the night little kid has
sleep deprivation it's probably not good
for me I supplement with caffeine oh hi
nice try
alright sure one day I'll get these
maybe probably not right right right
keep going
we're gonna try it and if it works it
it'll work I don't know all right go
back up alright who's so little time I
don't know what that means
where's the Oh mean what is the Oh mean
look out for these [ __ ] in the
darkness where you at [ __ ] ooh there
you have all right we got waiting for us
hi Yaya Yaya Yaya okay well I seem to go
nowhere Hey Oh
I don't know I don't know what that
means join it eat eat eat okay any rats
around there okay all right then if you
say so but I don't know if it is so over
that's dangerous okay all right you know
we'll go for it the actors playing the
rat in the cat in the theater she'll
were horribly murdered Oh found dead and
bast after him by the actor playing the
puppeteer an actor was under the
influence and died of strangling his
opponent with the rim under the
underside of that of the costume costume
ads were airtight the actors had to get
air through the gap around the costume
neck okay
that's terrifying so why did that happen
why did they strangle ate themselves
Burma oh no bad hey JJ JJ yeah you doing
mud oh I almost stepped on you stepped
on you buddy I don't know where I'm gone
but it's probably bad my eyeballs are
bleeding you see where I am
okay all right I don't know if this is
continues on to ad infinitum but I have
a funny feeling I shouldn't be here yep
I reach the edge of the road where the
Frick do I go I'm never gonna all right
then well you got dark over here whoa
there's right over there why is it dark
here it got darker than he usually does
why do you do that
why did it do that okay I don't know
what to do about that but I think that's
all that I can do I I've wandered pretty
much everywhere in the darkness and seem
like exactly blazing for me to go look
things and stuff woo doodads and do
dongles an old photograph of me gray its
photographs of me and my family
Hey oh good right
tonight's the final night before you get
to see him again been an entire week but
tomorrow I'll probably have a solution
to these horrible nightmares okay
just one more night okay I trust you
100% with my life because I feel like
that's what I'm doing right now all
right let's do this they'll feel right
it's gonna be any tougher than the
thar's now I damn it I'm out of screw
okay all right then amazingly I did not
get screwed but I'm probably about to
whoa
[ __ ] yeah goddamn it you [ __ ]
trickster
yeah tricky dick get tricky yellow you
go down thank you
all righty then I can handle this well
that ain't good oh [ __ ]
oh no oh god damn it okay hi there
all right game over I'll never be able
to try again oh okay so anyway so that
is the end of this episode that's all
the time I got here so I need to solve
the fifth night and then mysteriously
more nights are gonna appear who'd known
that there would be more nights waiting
for me in the darkness but either way
thank you everybody so much for watching
only a couple more episodes maybe one to
go on this one
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
[Music]